[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le 1er juin 2010 est
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les invités l'écriture permet
quelques fois à chacun d'exprimer une
souffrance l'enfance brisée un abandon
c'est aussi un moyen de pardonner et
c'est le cas dans l'indispensable pardon
une autobiographie de victoires janot
qui réside aujourd'hui à guyancourt et
qui nous vient de martinique théâtre le
théâtre montansier de versailles a été
honoré lundi 29 mai à paris par
l'académie des molières les
professionnels décerné deux prix
allaient pièce co-produite par session
qui viennent récompenser le travail
d'exigence conduit par ce théâtre à
versailles un théâtre qui a accueilli
quarante mille spectateurs plus de 40000
spectateurs pour 115 représentations
depuis septembre 2016 mais nous
commençons ce magazine par de la
littérature avec cette autobiographie
touchante de victoires janot l'histoire
d'une jeune fille vivant en martinique
dont le père est parti
abandonnant toute sa famille l'attend la
souffrance puis sont arrivés en
métropole
c'est le récit de sa vie dans
l'indispensable pardon de victoires
janot rencontrées par mélanie poker
victoire janot bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes l'auteur de l'indispensable
pardon qu'est ce que c'est et bien c'est
vaste sujet j'ai choisi ce
ce titre là parce qu'il correspond bien
à mon histoire ma propre histoire
c'est un récit autobiographique de quoi
de votre enfance de votre vie entière
le tout un parcours tout par quoi oui
pour pas qu'on de vie voilà alors on y
attend quoi
et bien de ma petite enfance jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
voilà les aléas mais les hauts et bas
voilà voilà donc la licence à votre
pardon c'est un rapport aussi avec avec
mon père parce que les partis pour la
france dans les années cinquante six et
par la suite nous n'avons pas eu de ses
nouvelles voilà donc nous attendions un
rapatriement qu'il est jamais arrivé et
l'intermède le signe de vie pendant
pendant plus de temps voilà donc on a il
nous a lâchement abandonné avant qu'on
s'en rende compte que c'était son
intention en fait voilà vous parler de
la france de l'hexagone plus précisément
je pense que vous êtes né en martinique
ça raconte votre enfant sont martin et
sa wii donc c'est mon enfance de la
martinique puisque je suis né à la
martinique et jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui où je suis rentré en france
à l'âge de 19 ans et
j'ai construit ma vie de femme voilà je
me suis marié je vais en plan et et puis
mes déboires comme tout le monde les
hauts et mes bas voilà donc ce qui m'a
poussé un peu à écrire ce livre c'est
c'est justement un douloureux événement
qui m'a qui m'a vraiment qui a été un
élément déclencheur d'écrire ce livre et
j'ai choisi quand même de véhiculer tout
ce que j'avais à dire tout ce que
j'avais emmagasiné dont je voulais me
débarrasser aussi c'était l'occasion de
le véhiculer par l'écriture
voilà donc ça c'est ça a fait cette
autobiographie qui retrace ma vie de mon
enfance à aujourd'hui je les écris parce
que c'était je devais pas que c'était
vital mais c'était vraiment j'avais
besoin de ça comme exutoire pour pour
pouvoir déposer savez tout le monde on a
tous notre petit tout petit baluchon à
porter avec soin les ovales ou à
s'alléger
mais à un moment donné on a besoin de le
poser parce qu'ils pèsent trop donc l
événement douloureux qui m'est arrivé en
2009 je parlerais délais sinon donc ça
m'a c'est là que ça a été l'élément
déclencheur et il fallait c'était
c'était une évidence
merci l'étranger nous non merci
[Musique]
théâtre maintenant avec le théâtre
montansier doublement dans l'actualité
avec trois molières attribué à deux
pièce co produite par le théâtre
versaillais mais également un événement
dans la ville
ce mois ce mois molière 22e édition qui
débute aujourd'hui
les jeunes deviennent riches auront vous
êtes la directrice du théâtre montansier
bonjour alors vous devez être très
honorée très contente de ces
distinctions
alors on est content on est surtout
content pour les artistes est content
d'avoir été associé à ces deux
spectacles parce qu'on les a coproduit
et donc on a accompagné les artistes et
permet ces deux créations les femmes
savantes avec le théâtre de la porte
saint-martin et puis réparer les vivants
avec le cdn de caen qui me permet aussi
de dire que au théâtre montansier on
travaille avec le théâtre public et le
théâtre privé ce qui est un des rares
cas en france puisque généralement ces
deux camps au style réparer les vivants
c'était une là d une adaptation d'un
roman de maylis de kerangal qui raconte
une journée fulgurante d'un jeune qui
part faire du surf qui au retour un
accident de voiture
il n'est pas guérissable se pose la
question de la greffe l'information des
parents le consentement
là on arrive sur le choix de du receveur
et le spectacle se termine par cette
femme de 50 ans qui recevra le coeur
d'un jeune de 18 ans c'est plein
d'espoir c'est pas du tout il n'y a pas
de pathos n'y a pas de tristesse
il ya l'espoir aussi et cette fulgurance
et 7 vitesses qui assure andré manel
noblet puisqu'il interprète tous les
rôles du roman et je crois que dans dans
l'histoire les parents sont par contre
veulent garder les yeux 2 oui on est
parents ne veulent pas qu'on prélève les
yeux et ils veulent aussi demande que
comme il aimait beaucoup la mer qu'au
moment où le transplante on lui met dans
les oreilles des bruits de vagues est
tout à fait
et donc quand j'avais 10 2 c'est bien
trois molières parce qu'il y à deux ans
perd 1,2 après que l'on connaît très
bien et jean pierre bacri et evelyne
buyle qui était donc deux interprètes
majeurs des femmes savantes dans une
mise en scène de catherine hiégel qui a
donc été produit par le théâtre de la
porte saint-martin jouets de septembre à
décembre et nous l'avons repris début
janvier avec grand succès et ensuite le
spectacle s'est arrêtée parce que c'est
la loi du genre
mais on était très heureux d'être
associé à ce projet majestueux vous
permettez que je parle d'un incubateur
un peu pour les théâtres montansier
c'est une expression
en tout cas vous vous mettez des
spectacles quelques fois avant paris
doit une fois après paris il n'y a pas
de règle en fait il n'y a pas de règle
et a pas non plus de règle en terme de
coproduction c'est à dire que
effectivement coproduit des artistes
connus des artistes en émergence ont
coproduit des compagnies voilà on a tous
les modes possibles d'accompagnement
notre souhait c'est vraiment d'être des
facilitateurs et d'aider la naissance de
spectacle pour le bonheur de nos
spectateurs
est ce qu'on peut parler en deux mots de
l'histoire de ce théâtre qui est quand
même un petit peu fakih havre a une
vraie histoire c'est vrai dans une ville
qui ont acquis on les remplit alors il a
été c'est l'oeuvre d'une femme qui
s'appelait marguerite brunet qui prend
ensuite le nom de montpensier qui est sa
tante elle est absolument toqués de
théâtre elle n'est en 1730 elle mourra
en 1820 donc elle traverse vraiment une
des périodes les plus agités de
l'histoire de france est elle construit
ce théâtre rue des réservoirs avec les
meilleurs faiseurs de l'époque
puisqu'elle fait travailler boulet
architecte du roi qui construira plus
tard le petit théâtre de la reine deux
ans après et elle y reçoit également la
cour c'est un théâtre de ville
dès l'origine qui accueille jusqu'à 1200
personnes puisqu'à cette époque les
spectateurs sont debout alors qu'istres
alors qu'aujourd'hui ils s'assoient et
donc ce théâtre sera rachetée au 19e par
la ville mais il est vraiment l'oeuvre
d'une femme qui est reconnu par les
économistes comme une des premières
femmes entrepreneures puisqu'elle se
construira ensuite le théâtre des
variétés à paris
je crois que le théâtre du palais royal
et elle dirigera une vingtaine de
théâtre en france on c'est une histoire
incroyable
la seule chose qu'elle ne fait pas c'est
de jouer parce qu'elle a gardé l'accent
un accent du sud ouest
mais sinon elle choisit des pièces elles
les organise elle fait les tournées de
alors donc un peintre qui a été restauré
oui plusieurs restaurations successives
la dernière en 92
il a au 19e il a été peint en rouge
puisque c'était la mode aujourd'hui il
est dans les bleus d'origine
et puis c'est un théâtre qui est dédié
majoritairement la création sous toutes
ses formes
et puis aussi un peu une politique
d'accueil de spectacles d'ores et déjà
créé et on accueille voilà un nombre de
spectateurs important 50% extérieurs à
la ville
ce qui est aussi un bon indicateur alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler a
justement là où commence le mois molière
c'est moi
ce soir tout à fait un petit peu du
programme du théâtre montansier ce
mois-ci molière alors le mois molière
c'est 350 spectacle 4 au théâtre
montansier d'abord la proposition
interprété notamment par christophe
barbier et anne coutureau ensuite abidal
ce parti qui est une coproduction que
nous avons fait avec le poche qui est
une soirée années 70 qui va déraper
complètement et révéler les caractères
des différents protagonistes
ensuite nous aurons amok qui est
interprété par eux alexis mango roman
torje et c'est une magnifique nouvelle
de stefan zweig et puis nous terminerons
avec un spectacle que nous avons déjà
programmé qui est repris les petites
reines qui est une adaptation du roman
de clémentine beauvais et qui est plus
spécialement destinée aux ados puisqu'il
y est question du harcèlement sur
internet
trois jeunes filles qui vont être nommés
boudin d'or boudin d'argent et baudin
bronze dans leur école et au lieu de
s'enfermer elles vont se donner le défi
de rejoindre paris et la garden party de
l'elysée en bicyclette puisqu'elles ont
chacune un compte à rendre à cette
occasion et du coup elles réussiront à
sortir de cette névrose qu'est le
harcèlement et à revivre et à combattre
ce méfait de nous ça nous a permis aussi
de travailler avec les ados sur ce sujet
et qu'il puisse en parler et que tout
d'un coup sur scène et voient leurs
contemporains avec des problématiques
qu'ils rencontrent tous les jours
justement je crois que vous avez une
politique d'ouverture vers un au public
plus jeune
vous accueillez fréquemment des écoles
des élèves de tout âge est ce que
justement dans votre choix de
programmation il ya un petit peu
justement d'ouverture à tous les publics
alors on essaie vraiment d'être ouvert à
tous les publics des plus jeunes au tout
public et surtout on a une politique
tarifaire exceptionnel le soir puisque
tous les soirs de spectacle on peut
venir trois quarts d'heure avant et pour
acheter un billet à 5 euros
voilà ce qui permet de dire que c'est
très facile d'aller au théâtre et de se
décider
quarante cinq minutes avant la
représentation et ensuite effectivement
au programme majoritairement du théâtre
contemporain classique visuel humour le
théâtre jeune public mais aussi de
l'opéra de la musique de la danse du
cirque
l'idée c'est vraiment la
pluridisciplinarité dans l'exigence et
la qualité artistique
mais ça c'est assez reconnus
j'aimerais que vous nous parlez plus
généralement du mois molière ça va être
vraiment un mois extraordinaire pour le
théâtre et l'art en général à versailles
alors le mois molière c'est 350
spectacle dans toute la ville partout
dans les parcs les places les lieux
la chapelle du lycée hoche les grandes
écuries évidemment pour des spectacles
majeurs des troupes des professionnels
des amateurs des lectures des débats le
plus souvent en entrée gratuite
et c'est vraiment le théâtre qui
investit la ville dans toute sa
dimension et pour un public local mais
aussi pour un public qui vient de
l'extérieur qui tout d'un coup est
associée au spectacle d'une autre
manière
merci beaucoup alors je rappelle nos
invités victoire janot pour son livre
l'indispensable pardon chez vérone
édition et geneviève dichamp est
directrice du théâtre montansier à
versailles est à l'honneur pendant ce
mois molière événements de la cité
royale
c'est la fin de ce sept huit invités
merci de votre fidélité
reflet sur notre site internet tv fil 78
points comme et si on notre application
bonne soirée
[Musique]